بمثل الحاح اقصى ايام الحرب وربما اكثر
تبدو حاجه السوريين الان لمدي يد العون
اليهم في كل شيء خصوصا لانقاذ العالقين
تحت ركام المباني التي هدمها زلزال كهرمان
مراش الدفاع المدني السوري في مناطق
المعارضه شمالا اطلق نداءات عاجله طلبا
للمساعده ومثله فعل النظام ومع ان الظرف
الانساني واحد قاهر وعصيب لكن الظروف
السياسيه لكل منطقه من سوريا تفرض نفسها
في هذا الوقت فمناطق المعارضه لديها معبر
واحد يسمح من خلاله بدخول المساعدات
الدوليه بتفويض اممي يجدد كل سته اشهر هو
معبر باب الهوى مع تركيا بعد اصرار الروسي
والنظام السوري على اغلاق معبر باب
السلامه في ريف حلب خلال السنوات الماضيه
اما في مناطق النظام السوري فتكثر
الخيارات البريه منها والجويه وهي مطرح
حلب ودمشق اللذان بدا فعلا باستقبال شحنات
المساعدات المقدمه من دول عربيه وغيرها
اضافه لمعابر بريه مع دول الجوار بحسب و
الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد فان
العقوبات الامريكيه المفروضه على النظام
تفاقم من سوء الاوضاع رغم تاكيد الجانب
الامريكي استثناء المساعدات الانسانيه من
تلك العقوبات وهو نفس الاستثناء الذي نص
عليه قرار مجلس الامن الاخير بشان وصول
المساعدات الى سوريا ايضا ابدت جهات سوريه
ومنها الهلال الاحمر السوري العامل في
مناطق النظام استعدادها لايصال المساعدات
الى كل المناطق حتى الخارجه عن سيطره
الحكومه وفق وصفها وهو مطلب لطالما اصر
النظام السوري ومعه روسيا على تحقيقه في
مجلس الامن اي ان يتولى النظام السوري
وتوزيع المساعدات في مناطقه ومناطق
المعارضه عبر ما يطلق عليها ادخال
المساعدات عبر خطوط التماس وهي اليه تعيب
المعارضه منظمات انسانيه في الشمال السوري
عليها ان النظام لا يوصل عبرها من
المساعدات سوى النذر اليسير كما انه يسعى
من خلالها الى تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه الثابت
ان زلزال كهرمان ماراش ادخل الجميع في
مضمار السباق مع الوقت فمع كل دقيقه تمر
يتكشف الحجم الحقيقي للكارثه سواء في
تركيا او في سوريا